the NFL has changed more in the last 15
years than the previous 35 at this rate
Super Bowl 100 could be unrecognizable
from Super Bowl 50 machine learning data
analytics is touching almost all aspects
of professional sports in some capacity
you can see a huge shift towards
computers actually running the strategic
decisions behind a lot of sports teams
which will allow coach just kind of
focus more on player development and
things of that nature the difference
between winning or losing and today's
NFL is so thin team two looking for an
edge anywhere they can get it and this
is a huge area where teams can improve
we checked in with a high school coach
in Little Rock whose food thinking just
may provide a glimpse of the game play
in the future when I took over in 2003
as the head coach at this program I look
back at the history of the program and
they had never been past the Final Four
in the history of the program in like 40
years and and I thought you know
nothing's gonna change and and I didn't
look to change it just to change it but
I wanted to build a base decisions on
data rather than basing decisions on gut
feeling off a lot of coaches like to do
found out that fill position it nearly
as important as people think and from
that point we started punting less and
less and over the years got to a certain
point with that the next thing we
started looking at was fill positions on
or after kickoff
and not just field position itself but
you start looking at when a team gets
the ball on their own 25 what percentage
the times they score from that point as
opposed to what percentage time would
they score if you onside kicked it then
you bring into the equation turnover and
then how those factor in and couldn't
cause some turnovers by onside kicking
and we integrated all that stuff and we
came up with our own way of playing the
game polka despite coach Kelly's
impressive turnaround
winning five state championships since
2003 the NFL and the college game have
been slow to adapt his methods so it's
human nature to not want to go against
the grain against the change and the
irony is if they would have gone for it
they upped their chances to win the game
at that line so they're actually hurting
their chances of keeping their job in
some respect
but what if a supercomputer told you
that not taking risks was the riskiest
thing you could do we checked in with
swish analytics in San Francisco to see
the role that supercomputers currently
have in the game of football
so we are swish analytics swish is a
machine learning platform for sports
data specifically focused on predictive
insights for the sports betting and
fantasy worlds as well as real-time
prediction so we're collecting thousands
of data points before the game and
obviously during the game and we are
producing a number of different
predictions
so if our models feel that the next play
will be a past that is obviously going
to affect the potential output for a
receiver on the team versus a run where
it would be a have a bigger impact on
the running back or basically for a team
they are definitely have you know access
to the technology to implement a optimal
play calling system where a coach can be
at least given recommendations out of
his thousands of plays that he has
access to here are the top three most
optimal plays to achieve a first down a
touchdown or whatever you know the
specific play calls for coaches have
access to computer data right now and
they use it but a lot of the coaches
personality a lot of emotion comes into
it
what if there was a computer instead of
a coach it could be a very interesting
experiment what if he took human emotion
out of it altogether you might be in the
best play every time throughout a
60-minute game that's a huge advantage
because even the best coaches you know
there's no way they're making the right
call all the time
it is not too far off that a
supercomputer or machine learning
algorithm could be actually calling
plays during a game assigning strategies
or personnel decisions the fact of the
matter is a computer and a set of
algorithms can process an exponentially
large amount of data points during a
live game that's super important so
right now coaches are making decisions
based off of let's say five data points
you know who the quarterback is what the
weather's doing how the defense is
playing he can actually then start
making decisions off of thousands of
data points and possibly those decisions
can be made with really without his
consideration sometime down the road
technology keeps on improving and it's
just gonna get more and more into the
game
I think smart teams can't afford to be
left behind this announced is gonna have
a huge impact on the future of the NFL
so Super Bowl 150 years from now we
imagine a supercomputer actually making
most of the decisions in terms of a play
call now the coach will act more as a
quality assurance manager so they'll
have some kind of digital clipboard
where they can actually either intervene
and override the play or they can throw
a wild card in there if they're kind of
a gambler type of coach and they really
want to throw a long the supercomputer
on the other sideline which is you know
calling the defense we imagine that
being relayed right down to the
quarterback and actually the play being
called by a supercomputer maybe
supercomputers are gonna be making the
calls in the future but the biggest
mystery is exactly what those plays will
actually look like so we're to a point
now where they want to see more plays in
a segment amount of time the general
public guys I think will reach where
they want to see more plays that don't
end so maybe then we do start lateral we
do start doing those types of things if
we find a way to fit them into winning
as well I think you can see teams
continue to tweak the way they play
offense to make it more vertical as
teams can refine their short yardage
offense I think a lot of teams are gonna
start going for two more often in the
future you get two super
400 in the score literally it could be
like a basketball NBA score it'll be you
know in the upper nineties a team it
might be like the last 10 times this
team scored over 100 they've won the
game and we saw those stats now are like
what are they talking about the days of
the the Gipper at the chalkboard those
are long gone I mean this is like any
business computers have had a huge
impact and they're going to continue
that more of an impact but there's also
going to be a place in there for the
guys that master the technology as well
and the use of it and Trust it the guys
that master that and know when to use it
are the ones that are going to be really
successful